hier hier hier oder auch hier könnte was
drin sein dass dich krank war
in den meisten fällen ist das sind
deutschland nicht der fall
eigentlich sind unsere lebensmittel
sicher eigentlich wenn unser
kontrollsystem scheitert oft immer
häufiger werden lebensmittel
zurückgerufen
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an die
kollektive angst vor gurken sprossen
frischmilch eiern rindfleisch oder eben
auch wurst die liste der
lebensmittelskandale ist lang
vergammeltes fleisch verdreckte
produktionsräume unmenschliche
arbeitsbedingungen
diese ekel bilder aus der firma wilke
stehen für den letzten großen skandal
stück für stück kam auch hier mehr infos
ans licht und 25 menschen könnten daran
verstorben sein
wieder einmal sind wir alle angewidert
und empört wieder einmal wurde spät
allem jetzt zu wenig kontrolliert und zu
spät gehandelt es ist ein skandal mit
ansage wir sehen dass die gleichen dinge
schief gelaufen sind jetzt in der summe
so ziemlich alles schiefgelaufen was
schieflaufen kann und solche fälle sind
jederzeit wieder möglich denn unser
system hat schwächen und lücken und es
könnte sogar noch schlimmer werden
[Musik]
wir verlassen uns darauf dass verdorbene
lebensmittel nicht zu uns in den
kühlschrank oder auf unseren teller
kommen weil die hersteller weil die
restaurants oder weil staatliche stellen
dafür sorgen dass das nicht passiert und
wir verlassen uns darauf dass alles
streng kontrolliert wird
nur leider stimmt das nicht immer allein
2018 werden nachweisbar elf todesfälle
324 krankenhausaufenthalte und über
2.400 erkrankung mit lebensmitteln
verbindung gebracht schätzungen zufolge
sind es insgesamt 100.000 erkrankungen
durch lebensmittel im jahr
und das kommt nicht aus dem nichts denn
unser system hat lücken und ist
überlastet
aber der reihe nach ein zentraler
kritikpunkt ist grundlegend seit 1997
kontrollieren die betriebe sich in
erster linie selbst das ist politisch
gewollt und so genehmigt das heißt über
eine million molkereien schlachtbetriebe
cafés restaurants imbisse kioske
supermärkte und so weiter sind selbst
dafür verantwortlich die richtlinien und
grenzwerte einzuhalten
sie kontrollieren sich selbst und in den
meisten fällen geht das gut aber hygiene
und ordentliche kontrollen sind teuer
und schwarze schafe beginnen hier zu
sparen wie wahrscheinlich auch
willkommen um das zu verhindern gibt es
amtliche kontrollen die kontrollieren in
erster linie was die unternehmen bei den
eigenen kontrollen selbst aufgeschrieben
haben und den äußeren eindruck und diese
kontrollen finden immer seltener statt
einer der hauptgründe dafür ist massiver
personalmangel und das problem ist
überhaupt nicht neu 2001 während der bse
krise lässt der akute personalmangel die
nötigen kontrollen nicht zu 2010 nach
dem sieben menschen an verseuchten käse
starben ist das problem nummer eins zu
wenig personal
und so könnte man jetzt hunderte
meldungen zitieren es ist seit jahren
dasselbe problem der verband der
lebensmittelkontrolleure spricht sogar
von jahrzehnten die zuständige
ernährungs ministerin julia klöckner
will jetzt dass die länder für mehr
personalsorgen alle beteiligten gehört
wir müssen mit ausreichend
qualifiziertem personal versorgt sein
wenn es um unsere gesundheit geht darf
nicht gespart werden denn ohne personal
keine kontrollen und weil diese
kontrollen im ländersache sind fühlt
sich das ministerium nicht weiter
verantwortlich ob sich jetzt also was
ändert bleibt abzuwarten
jedenfalls wunder dass ein kaum das
foodwatch herausgefunden hat dass jede
dritte kontrolle ausfällt gerade mal
zehn prozent von knapp 400 behörden
schaffen ist die kontrollen
durchzuführen die sie müssten da kann
man sich gut vorstellen dass unternehmen
die schlampig und unsauber arbeitende
durchs raster rutschen oder das ganze
ausnutzen auch bei weg sind teilweise
kontrollen ausgefallen und trotzdem
wurden mehrmals menge erkannt und
bußgelder verhängt und trotzdem kam
verseuchtes fleisch auf den markt mit
fatalen folgen dann waren wieder alle
empört und so auch die zuständige
ministerin glöckner
jetzt soll sich alles verändern und
alles soll besser werden und da ist uns
ein entwurf für eine verordnung
untergekommen die das ganze ein bisschen
anders darstellt in zukunft könnten es
nämlich noch weniger kontrollen werden
nach der neuen fassung wären wir ja bei
vierteljährlich das heißt alle drei
monate statt zwölf kontrollen vier
kontrollen also die kontrollen werden
billiger
wie kann das jetzt sein dafür sollen die
risikogruppen in der neuen av vrb neu
definiert werden und außerdem verändert
sich die frequenz der pflicht kontrollen
wenn man die beiden fassungen
übereinander legt sieht man aus der
täglichen kontrolle wird eine
wöchentliche und aus der monatlichen
wird hier mal im jahr
verbraucherschützer und der verband der
lebensmittelkontrolleure halten von der
d dementsprechend nichts für sie steht
fest da wird auf dem papier schön
gerechnet dass kontrolleure fehlen in
dem man die aufgaben verkleinert im
ministerium sieht man das anders und
erklärt dass man dadurch dass man
weniger routinekontrollen macht mehr
risikokontrollen machen
man will sich jetzt also stärker auf die
schwarzen schafe konzentrieren und da
effizienter kontrollieren und steht
damit aber ziemlich alleine da
der finale text für die verordnung steht
auch noch nicht und die auslegung bleibt
am ende dann wieder ländersache
nach mehr sicherheit für unsere
lebensmittel klingt das allerdings nicht
denn was uns auch klar sein muss von den
meisten mängeln und verstößen bekommen
überhaupt nichts mit auch unser rückrufs
system ist noch nicht einmal bundesweit
einheitlich oder wirklich übersichtlich
und die ergebnisse der meisten
kontrollen sind noch nicht mal
öffentlich das ist in vielen eu ländern
anders und das zeigt uns auch ein weg
wie wir es besser machen könnten in
dänemark norwegen und wales zeigen zum
beispiel smileys an der tür von
restaurants wie sauber oder nicht sauber
da gearbeitet wird und in frankreich
kann man die kontrollergebnisse online
abrufen
in deutschland gibt es in manchen
städten zwei initiativen aber ein
bundesweites system ist nicht geplant
wir versuchen dass verbraucherschützer
wie foodwatch sogar mit eigenen
verfahren alles in allem muss uns bei
unserem jetzigen system klar sein dass
in einer branche die so sehr unter
preisdruck steht und in der so wenig
kontrolliert wird der nächste skandal
sicher ist die neue verordnung wird das
nicht verbessern sondern
höchstwahrscheinlich sogar noch
verschlimmern
klar ist auch mehr kontrollen können
fehler nicht ganz ausschließen aber wenn
irgendwo mängel und dreck gefunden
werden dann sollten wir verbraucher das
so schnell und so einfach wie möglich
erfahren
und daran kann man ganz sicher arbeiten
[Musik]